bismillah humble assalamu alaikum peace
be with you I'm at your house and you're
watching the Deen show thank you for
tuning in to another exciting episode
we're gonna be talking about Easter its
origins with the author of holiday myths
doctor Hakim quick who is a PhD a
historian and he's going to ask
answering some questions about Easter
its origins where it originated from so
you can be enlightened here on the Deen
show don't go nowhere we'll be right
back
assalamu alaikum peace be with you when
it comes to our how are you sure I'm
doing that fine thank you for being with
us here on the Deen show people can go
to the Deen show.com to read it about
you you're a historian you're an Islamic
scholar first graduate American graduate
or Canadian graduate of American
American from the Medina Islamic
University okay and you got your PhD
from University of Toronto Toronto so
we're talking to an expert in this area
that now Jesus peace be upon him who no
Muslim is a Muslim unless he believes in
Jesus the same way believe in Moses
Abraham Noah and the last and final
messenger prophet peace be upon him this
is a confusion over this mighty message
some people take him as God some people
take him as a literal son of God and
some people say that he died was
resurrected and they're celebrating
Easter so people of consciousness that
are out there that you know what they're
wanting to know more they're not really
you know settling with the whole Trinity
and Jesus dying you know and for their
sins so we want to talk about Easter its
origins and shed some light on the
confusion so people have a better
understanding right talk to us about
this holiday Easter again it is
important for us to look at the two
streams one stream is the stream of
tawheed monotheism and that is where the
great messengers of god of allah
subhanaw taala came to the earth and we
know there was Abraham Jacob Moses Jesus
Mohammed so many of these great
messengers who came to the world and
taught the people that they should not
worship human beings they should not
worship created things but they should
worship the creator himself so did they
come with different religions for
different times like here God sent a
messenger said worship me is a calf
another one said worship me as a man
another one said worship me as a woman
what was God doing that no one message
but what we see is that you know the
quran is saying in the chapter of the b
verse 36 and verily we have sent to
every nation a messenger that they
worship one god and stay away from false
gods so so the unifying
factor in all of the messages is toe
heat and that is monotheism the strict
belief in one God it is the first and
greatest commandment
we're goddess a hero Israel the Lord
your God is one and this is the way it
was with all of the messages and so
coming into the life of Jesus Ethernet's
Salam from our perspective and we see
ourselves again not as being something
new but as an extension of the belief in
one God from our perspective he was a
mighty Messenger of God sent to the
children of Israel he came not to
destroy or to change the law of Moses he
came to fulfill the law and he received
the injeel he recieved the Gospels and
because of his teachings although the
teachings were so life-giving and the
miracles that that happened to him he
was actually misunderstood and he was
driven away and the Roman Empire at the
time saw him as a revolutionary or
subversive and because of this he was
under attack he came with a very
straightforward belief he used to dress
very simply sometimes wear no shoes a
very humble person not the image that
you get this godlike image that you get
which is really Michelangelo who drew
his uncle in the Sistine Chapel it's not
that individual this is a simple person
even described in some of the biblical
descriptions as a person with curly here
and skin like burnt brass completely
different would he resemble like someone
from the Arabian Peninsula like a
somatic persons on them from the Middle
Eastern area yeah that's what he
actually was not blond hair blue eyes no
that's Michelangelo he was uncle in the
Sistine Chapel and then everybody took
the picture as being you know Jesus
Christ but but easily so now he was a
carpenter so his hands were tough his
feet were you know tough it's not the
image that you get it's a completely
different image the important issue
however is the message and that was the
straight belief in one God so where's
the Easter coming from now what now
we'll talk again we
I thought that easily Salaam when he was
under this pressure he gathered his
followers together in the Last Supper
which someone just heard you say easily
some and now are our brothers our
humanity Krishna what anytime I Issa
what about Jesus Jesus whose ISA ISA is
literally the Semitic way the Arabic way
of saying Jesus so cuz did the English
language wasn't around was it right so
so this is just a mispronunciation of
the word actually Jesus yeah Jesus but
but will say Jesus are so people can you
know kasher what we're saying
so now Jesus calls his followers
together for a Last Supper al-ma'idah
and and Allah God brings down food in
the table they eat from the food now
they have a sign from God and within
that Jesus prays to God save me by any
means necessary so according to our
understanding after this last supper
Jesus was raised and the Romans
continued Allah knows best what happened
there's a lot of different reports
somebody was on the cross but according
to our teachings the Quran says warm up
a Telugu War masala boohoo
why Lacan should be other who say this
is just a verbatim word of god this is
the last Testament saying they did not
kill him they did not crucify him but it
was made to appear to them that they did
this is Allah the Creator that all that
exists the creator of Jesus roles is the
one God he is revealing this he's saying
this that's right because even according
to the traditions of Judaism and Rome
that you know the death on the cross is
the death of a criminal so it is not
like a lecture chair yeah it's even
worse than that because it's humiliation
because when you're dying on the cross
obviously you know it is a very
humiliating thing for a person to die in
front of other individuals so the cross
saying that this he was safe from this
humiliation was oh so we believe he was
saved from the humiliation the point is
he is raised okay he's alive and he will
return before the day of judgment so
this is our understanding some of the
Christian churches come later and say no
he was on the cross and he died and then
later he was resurrected
that is another debate within itself the
key issue however is that originally
Jesus was sent clearly with the belief
in one God there is no doubt about that
and the belief in focusing not on
natural things but focusing on the
Creator now in Europe itself in other
parts of the world was Sun worship in
Sun worship the people are following the
movements of the planets they are
following reproduction and they are
following the seasons so in the spring
season called the spring solstice during
that time winter has ended
and remember winter in the northern
countries is death it's snowing outside
the trees are dead animals hibernate
nothing is around if you don't have
central heating somebody's going to die
in your own family so it's a time of
death and famine and it's very dark out
in the northern countries but when the
spring comes it is a time of life so
therefore they developed a nature cult
and the goddess for the cult
her name was aa stray or Easter and they
believed that Easter would wave her wand
and everything now turns green so this
is the concept now and that's the reason
why people today if you mentioned the
word Easter they will say bunny rabbits
chickens eggs lilies they'll talk about
fertility symbols natural they won't
talk about Jesus they won't talk about
me or the Jewish law of Moses because
what happened is somehow somewhere along
the line the followers of Jesus what was
left of his message was incorporated
into the nature belief so therefore
instead of death winter changing into
spring resurrection of nature it was now
the death on the cross and the
resurrection
so they amalgamated the two so that
those who worship nature and the
changing of nature they could celebrate
alongside of those who had the the
teachings of Jesus so what this has
created is a confusion
those who want to go back to the
original message and to be involved in
pure revelation and to follow the
message of God they are confused between
the nature-based religions sexuality is
pushed up in the front and between the
law of God where sexuality has its place
and where respect is there society is
there and all worship is for the creator
of the heavens and the earth only for
the one created the one supreme being
God Almighty that's okay we're gonna
take a break and be right back with more
here on Dean show one God worship him
alone do what he wants you to do put
your desire is this thing inside you
that just wants this and wants that and
you just can't get enough you know what
you'll never get enough until the dirts
in your mouth don't let it come to that
be sincere and honest ask the one who
created you to guide race the first step
put off chasing all the women and the
good times and the parties and this and
that there is no one worthy of worship
except Allah don't wait you never know
if death would come today for you
it's a way of land or to us bad the
messenger best of me show us the way to
Alyce quiz this is the D Deena that's
gonna be show and dr. Abdullah King
quick we're talking about Easter and we
never want to offend anybody we're just
trying to deliver the truth and have
people ponder and think so you're an
historian a scholar in this area tell us
now did Jesus peace be upon him whose
beloved to our heart did he ever call
people he used to be a former Christian
and you investigated other world
religions and this one in particularly
do you ever see him calling people to
worship himself as a God next together
this is what I found in the beginning
that really there was a contradiction
between the doctrine of some of the
churches and the actual sayings and
teachings of Jesus because when you look
at the sayings and teachings of Jesus
who said I did not come to destroy or to
change the law of Moses but I came to
fulfill the law you will see that he was
a strict monotheists because that's the
first commandment and as the Quran says
itself the last Testament when it speaks
about Jesus and his mother
it said can i you : eat Tom they used to
eat food so by saying they used to eat
food it means they're human beings so he
was a humble human being he was a
prophet he was a message of miracles
came he was able to cure that the sick
that the lepers make the blind to see
but he always said I did this by the
permission of God this is not me who's
doing it I am a vessel of the power and
mercy of the Creator and that is the
difference between the two beliefs
because within the Mediterranean region
the Greek and Roman concept gave godlike
status to people or it made the gods
seem like people so therefore when you
the Zeus or you see Jupiter coming down
to earth and getting angry with people
and then he has a human being and his
son is Hercules so this is God's
intermingling with people so that
concept was there in the ancient world
Mithras the concept of Mithras who is
this individual who was the son of God
who comes down to sacrifice himself for
the four human beings
his sacred day is the seventh day of the
week which we call now son day his
followers used to put an ashen mark on
their head
he had a communion made of wafers like
bread and wine these teachings existed
they were not in the law of Moses it was
not amongst the recorded teachings of
Jesus peace be upon him and so the
amalgamation comes with a form of
religion whether even the sign of the
Cross is the symbol of eternal life that
was used thousands of years before Jesus
this is amalgamated into the teachings
and so what we're trying to say is with
all respects for for people who are
searching for truth we need to separate
those things that are folk fables and
folk culture from Revelation we have to
separate the two because we want the
revelation we want to submit to God and
to be as pure as we possibly can and not
to be submitting to material things and
worshipping idols are worshiping nature
goddesses and whatnot we've gone past
this point there are many people have
gone past that point and they want to
know what did the prophets actually say
so tell us now dr abdul hakeem quick for
the person says look you mentioned
monotheism when were monotheists - we
believe in one God three Father Son Holy
Ghost one God you believe in one God the
same thing you know how would you
respond to this I would respond to say
that go back to the ancient teachings of
Plato and you will see in Plato's
teachings he believed in a type of logos
he believed that there was the one
reason for things to be is like the
Father and then there is the Son and
then there is the Holy Spirit
this actually came out of plato's
teachings you will also find in ancient
Egypt they had Horus Isis and Osiris the
ancient Indians also had this concept in
Hinduism
so the Trinity concept was not a new
concept it was in the ancient world
again it has nothing to do with the old
testament he has nothing to do it but
Jesus is teachings but it is an
amalgamation to bring that concept in
because strict monotheism does not
divide God into three parts
nor does God have the ability or even
want to change himself into a human
being and come down on earth this is
part of the Greek Roman mythology it's
not part of the of the teachings that
came to the great prophets of monotheism
so what we're saying is that we want to
separate folk culture from revelation we
want to go back to the pure teachings
that would be in line with the original
teachings of Abraham of Jacob of Moses
of Jesus Muhammad peace be upon them all
of the righteous prophets that is the
family of Islam and we don't see a
difference between ourselves and the
original pure followers of Moses the
pure followers of Jesus we are all
originally coming from the same source
and we will eventually go back to the
same source tell us now say for the
person who's confused this is making
sense only worshipping the Creator not
what he created submitting to him on his
terms not your desires your opinions
your wants and I submit to God but now
does it start with praying to God alone
and asking for guidance because you see
a lot of people praying through Jesus
and saying look Jesus said that no one
comes to the Father except through me
or they'll pray through the creation to
get to God what's the severity of this
why why is this is this something that
God is gonna not be pleased with that
this is insulting to God and why would
it be insulting together well we have to
remember that the first and greatest
commandment of the ten is that you
should worship one God so this is the
greatest commandment and you'll see
within the teachings of all of the
prophets that the most important aspect
is monotheism Coheed the belief in one
God and shirk polytheism is considered
to be the
possible sin that a human being can
commit to their blasphemy that's
blasphemy and it's polytheism you know
so it's it's really serious thing it
takes us out of the realm of the
monotheistic prophets and so it's really
important for people of conscience of
innocent people searching people to pray
to God themselves make a special prayer
to the creator ask the creator to guide
you because guidance is really a
personal thing religion cannot be forced
on other individuals it is not a debate
it is not a certificate you get in a
university that is something given by
God himself by the Creator so those who
are searching should pray to God ask God
to guide you as we constantly say
Muslims say constantly in their prayers
Medina sirat al-mustaqim guide us to the
straight path even though we are Muslims
we believe we submit we constantly ask
Allah to guide us and that is the most
important thing for people today that is
so simple to understand
asking God starting with wanting it and
then asking God Almighty alone not his
creation not going through Muhammad or
through Jesus or through anybody but why
do you think it is that you know many
people they fall into this trap they
fall into this trap of calling on other
than God they feel like you know what we
can't go too straight to God because
we're not holy enough our problem as
human beings one of our great challenges
is that we are tested constantly with
our senses we taste we see we hear
and so therefore material things it is
easier to worship something material
something you can see something you can
hear something which is visibly in front
of you and that is the reason why Sun
worship was always the greatest worship
in the ancient world because the Sun is
the largest of the creation the Sun
gives you heat and life and so people
naturally were geared toward the Sun but
when we get the full picture we realized
that the Sun is a creation in itself
that the universe was once one unit and
it was split apart this is the Big Bang
Theory and this is what the final
testament
Quran says in the chapter of anbiya that
this is the creation so therefore it's
easy to worship the material things
because that's right in front of us but
where the challenges is for the greater
picture to see the Creator who has
created the systems who has created all
the things that we see and all the
things that we taste that is the
challenge on human beings it is a
natural thing the child when the baby is
born as a Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him said every child is born on the
fitrah in a natural way the child cries
out to the mother the child has a
natural belief that the mother will
respond that the creation is there to
benefit him is a natural feeling of the
oneness of God in every child that we
believe is Islam so every child
originally is a Muslim and that does not
mean they speak Arabic or they live in
the Middle East this is something all
races all nationalities everybody is a
Muslim in the beginning and it is their
family that then gear them towards their
culture if the culture is based on Sun
worship it is based on nature if it is
based on worship of the dollar bill or
the pound or the rupee of the rial then
that's the way they go if it is based on
the worship of God then they are geared
toward that what we say now is we are an
age of information we are an age of
knowledge so we need to pray to God
investigate and and try to find the true
religion and ask God to keep you on the
straight path we'll be right back here
on the Deen show with more so type
I just want to say very simple message
one of the beautiful things about our
religion of Islam is the emphasis on
direct ritual and prayer who God
there is no intermediary the lights will
go on after the party and the party will
end it's very simple and very clear
there are no superstitious rituals no
strange incantations the time is running
out and you might not make it till
tomorrow and this is something that we
need to think about
it's a way of land
brought to us bad the messenger best of
me show us the way to Allah squeeze this
is the Deen he daddy's back here on the
Deen show with dr. Abdullah Hakeem quick
and we're talking about Easter and
you're linking it back to these had
pagan origins right Jesus never preached
teach what called anybody to worship Him
he never ever explicitly said that look
I'm God worship I'm the son of God
okay but some people would say look to
it before I go to tonight my main
question because we don't worship Him as
God he's just a son of God how would you
find this again it is how you use the
word son because really you'll see even
in biblical law traditions that human
beings are the children of God
you'll see the children of Israel called
the children of God so in a sense
because a human being has something from
the Creator our soul we are all children
of God in in the sense of the soul
because it comes from the Creator if you
take it to an animal level the son is
from the father this is an animal thing
this is where the mythology comes in
where the human being is literally the
son of the creator like Hercules is half
god and half men so this this is a
mythology based concept it's a
nature-based concept so that that's a
different it you know play on words so
people are using the same word but they
have a different concept Muslims we say
we're all the children of God God is the
father in a sense of he's the creator
sustainer he is that the one with the
most power the author of the systems of
life so that is a fatherly figure in a
greater sense metaphorically
metaphorically but not literally not any
animal father yeah animal father is the
one who had a sexual relationship with
your mother
that's an insult to God right you you're
putting down God to be a human being
and as the Quran said two about Jesus
and Mary they used to eat food so if you
eat food that means you was hungry and
you're going to the bed you got to go to
the bathroom and that is something which
the Creator is far above because the
Creator is not part of our world like a
created being that's the difference in
creator between alcoholic and Alma Luke
the Creator is the one who is perfect
and who is the creator of everything the
creation is the one who is created who
has hunger who has thirst who lives who
dies
that's the creation so the original
religions of all the prophets
separated creator from created and so by
doing that everything is in the right
perspective when you take the Creator
and make him create it now we're causing
a confusion because God can get angry
like a human being God can make mistakes
God can come down on earth and cause
confusion and people lose their
relationship with the Creator they lose
their respect for religion and this is
what is destroying belief in many people
because they see the gods as just you
know larger forms of human being who are
desire women and what power and
struggling with each other when we say
allah azza wajal
we are talking about the mighty the
majestic who is perfect the Creator the
one who has knowledge of all things the
one who existed before human beings
existed before anything existed we
cannot describe the Creator we cannot
put any human or natural physical
quality on the Creator that is the
teachings of the first commandment of
the ten commandments that is the
teachings of the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him and all those righteous ones
who came from the beginning of time and
that is the teaching I believe that
human beings need to return to in this
turbulent age that we are living in
today because we are worshipping money
we are worshipping sex we are
worshipping our tribe we are worshipping
power how many people want to be
President or prime minister or King and
they're fighting each other instead of
submitting to the create
instead of looking at life as a test and
trying to assist each other and
realizing how weak and humble
we actually are people try to be gods on
their own I believe it's important for
Muslims and all people of conscience go
back to the sources investigate humble
yourself turn to the creator and realize
that our life is short and we are going
on to the real life that is after death
that's the transition and we want to
enter into that world having pleased the
Creator so that we can be pleased with
what is coming in front of us and that's
so eloquently and beautifully put thank
you so much we're out of time and we
hope to have you back here in the Dean
show thank you once again for being us
may God Almighty the creator of love and
watch ami and thank you for sitting
through another episode of the Dene show
as you can see Easter really when you
look deep into it has nothing to do with
the teachings of Jesus peace be upon him
who is beloved to our hearts no Muslim
is a Muslim and Muslim is simply one who
has submitted consciously made the
decision that I'm not going to worship
the creation I'm going to worship the
one create tour and this is what Jesus
brought and taught to all of his
followers that don't worship the
creation worship the creator and so did
Moses Abraham Noah and the last and
final mission of problem Hama peace be
upon him and they never taught or
brought these ideas that man has
invented concocted that God could be a
man that God Almighty is having sons and
daughters and all these other man-made
inventions that the prophets were free
of the prophets came with that simple
message worship the Creator not his
creation so you got to listen to an
expert an historian someone who was a
former Christian and investigated all
the different world religions and came
to that conscious decision that you know
what Islam is the way of life that's
from the crater so I'm gonna do what God
wants me to do I'm gonna submit to God
on his terms
not my desires
and this is what we encourage everyone
to do out there to learn more you can
also reach us at one eight hundred six
six two is LOM and until next time peace
be unto you
it's a way of land
brought to us bad the messenger best of
me show us the way to alice Chris this
is the Dean did not is man